se espera que de esta cumbre
extraordinaria del 17 salgan acciones
concretas y urgentes para evitar que la
crisis humanitaria en afganistán siga
creciendo el primer ministro británico
gordon song que tiene la presidencia
este año del g7 dijo que toda la
comunidad internacional debe estar unida
para garantizar el éxito de las
evacuaciones y exigir que los derechos
de los afganos que han ganado en los
últimos años se respeten y es que el
reino unido- busca que ningún país en el
mundo reconozca de manera unilateral o
apresuradamente un gobierno del talibán
sin antes exigir estándares de respeto
de los derechos humanos los derechos de
las niñas y de las mujeres a seguir
educándose y a trabajar y que no se
permita la presencia de ninguna
organización terrorista como al qaeda
esto en medio de las críticas que siguen
creciendo aquí a nivel nacional por la
retirada de las tropas de terreno afgano
en las últimas horas el ex primer
ministro británico tony blair bien
importante porque bajo sus órdenes
empezó esta ocupación británica hace 20
años en afganistán dijo que si bien
respeta al presidente joe biden le
parece imbécil esa decisión de retirada
de las tropas americanas dijo que además
es trágica peligrosa e innecesaria dijo
blair a diferentes medios de
comunicación aquí en el reino unido- que
las tropas británicas pudieron
mantenerse más tiempo en terreno afgano
y que esta decisión puede derivar
incluso en una amenaza a la seguridad
del reino